so let's talk about the chart the
acceleration of AI progress oh man yeah
right leg what's this we're going down
the rabbit hole Elan thinks hey this
thing is gonna take off faster we're
gonna lose control or could lose control
we got to put some reins on him Larry
Page is like no let's just let it wild
and it eelain's being hyperbolic where
do you sit well I think our literature
general intelligence is extremely hard I
think it will take I'm taking the over
on 20 if I set the line at 20 yeah I'll
set the line at 20 is a fine line but
I'll take the over on these people who
think oh we're gonna have artificial
general intelligence singularity in five
years you know which I've heard a lot of
people talk about um we don't know you
don't know I mean that's really the
answer is I don't think like we know
exactly what what is going on I I
actually am extremely happy that there
is a large group of extremely smart
people at least joining together to talk
about this stuff and try and figure it
out right the impact on jobs is the one
that I think probably will have the most
impact on our society in the short to
mid-term I think the person running the
Treasury of the United States said that
AI will not impact jobs for another 50
to 75 years was the quote so I think
we're all taking the under there what
impact will this have on I won't give
you the easy one which is
self-driving retail and that kind of
stuff we know that's going but let's go
into the white-collar jobs law
accounting sales you know you know
marketing I don't know you know just
stuff in the middle here's my thesis on
this yeah Automation I'm not going to
call it artificial intelligent like you
know hardcore automation will have an
impact on every aspect of jobs
however since I'm going to take the over
on most you know people in Silicon
Valley's estimate on when we're gonna
have artificial general intelligence my
belief is that jobs that deal with human
caring or human to human communication
or that are going to accelerate rapidly
I think being a nurse practitioner
or a nurse or whatever is going to
accelerate rapidly in terms of job
demand humans were going to like to talk
and be communicated with by other humans
for a very very very long time in that
regard